dès le lendemain des législatives
l'assemblée nationale organise une
procédure d'accueil pour permettre aux
élus de s'approprier leur nouvel espace
de travail arrivé très tôt ce matin à 6h
karl olive le nouveau député de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines est l'un
des premiers à se présenter au palais
bourbon d'abord on a dormi peu on s'est
retrouvé très tôt ce matin à 6 heures
ici on a fait un peu le parcours
initiatique 1 c'est le même parcours que
le gamin qui va entrer pour la première
fois en section maternelle et puis il ya
évidemment l'émotion d'un enfant de la
république qui se retrouve au coeur de
la démocratie
aperçu également charles rodwell le
nouveau député de la première
circonscription en compagnie d'aurore
berger pour l'aider à prendre ses
marques chacun repart avec sa pochette
d'accueil comprenant son écharpe
tricolore
son nom signe sa cocarde et ses codes
informatiques pour se connecter à son
nouveau bureau parmi les huit
commissions permanentes à l'assemblée
nationale car le livre a ses préférences
moi j'aimerais intégrer la commission la
commission des lois gg un certain nombre
de sujets sur lequel je suis très
sensible le non-cumul député maire pour
moi c'est vraiment une connerie
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir des
remontées de terrain la création du
conseiller territorial également et puis
peut-être profiter de cet instant
historique en france pour bouleverser
aussi nos habitudes peut être changer
l'ordre de séquence électorale a apporté
un vote électronique faire de la
proportionnelle oui c'est il ya plein de
petites choses il faut en profiter la
les nouveaux députés ont jusqu'à
vendredi 24 juin pour se présenter à
l'assemblée nationale le mardi 28 juin
signera bel et bien la date de la
rentrée les 577 députés sont appelés à
siéger en séance publique pour
l'élection de celui ou de celle qui
présidera l'hémicycle